غارات تلو اخرى في اليوم الثالث من حمله
الانتقام الاسرائيليه الواسعه ضد قطاع غزه
الاهل باكثر من مليوني مدني
فلسطيني في كل ارجاء القطاع وبلا استثناء
تنهال الصواريخ والقذائف على المباني
السكنيه والاسواق والمدارس والمساجد وسائر
المرافق
المدنيه غارات الاثنين استهدفت حي الرمال
وسط غزه ودمرت اجزاء واسعه منه حيث قضت
عائلات باسرها تحت الركام الشهداء الذين
تم تكرر المشهد في مخيم جباليا والشاطئ
وتل الهواء وغيرها حيث اعلنت وزاره الصحه
في غزه ارتكاب الاحتلال مجازره بحق 13
عائله ادت الى استشهاد 105 من
ذويهم وفيما تت بيانات جيش الاحتلال عن
استهداف مزيد من المواقع التابعه لحركه
حماس تكشف الوقائع ان المستشفيات وسيارات
الدفاع المدني وطواقم الاسعاف باتت عمدا
وعن قصد ضمن بنك الاهداف الاسرائيلي اذ
خرجت نحو سبع مستشفيات عن الخدمه كليا او
جزئيا حتى الان كما قصفت اكثر من ع سيارات
اسعاف ومع انهيار القطاع الصحي رفض
اسرائيل طلبا عاجلا من اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر لفتح ممرات لنقل المصابين
للعلاج خارج القطاع اكثر من ذلك اعلن وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يف جالانت عن فصل جديد
من عمليه الانتقام ضد الفلسطينيين فقد امر
بفرض حصار كامل على غزه يقطع عنها الماء
والكهرباء
والغذاء الامين العام للامم المتحده حذر
من التداعيات الخطيره لتلك الخطوه ودع
المجتمع الدولي الى دعم فوري للجهود
الانسانيه في
القطاع اشعر بحزن عميق ازاء اعلان اسرائيل
بانها ستفرض حصارا كاملا على قطاع غزه لا
يسمح بدخول اي شيء لا كهرباء ولا طعام ولا
وقود كان الوضع الانساني في غزه سيئا
للغايه قبل اندلاع القتال والان سوف
يتدهور بشكل اكبر
وبينما تتدهور اكثر الاوضاع والخدمات
المترديه اصلا بسبب سنوات الحصار تحدثت
الامم المتحده عن نزوح نحو 120 الف شخص في
غزه من منازلهم جراء حمله القصف التي يؤكد
قاده جيش الاحتلال انها ستستمر بلا هواده
وانها لن تتاثر بوجود اسرى اسرائيليين في
المواقع المستهدفه
الله